imágenes como éstas se han vuelto cada
vez más comunes en américa latina' la
lista de los países que comienzan a
vacunar a sus niños aumenta el último en
sumarse fue brasil el país compró 20
millones de vacunas pediátricas para
aplicar en menores de 5 a 11 años la
vacunación no será obligatoria sin
embargo los gobiernos estatales podrán
decidir si deben haber recibido un
biológico para asistir a las escuelas a
pesar de la resistencia del presidente
jair bolsonaro yo te diré mi opinión mi
hija de 11 años no se va a vacunar
el panorama es distinto en costa rica en
donde el gobierno ya exige la vacunación
de los menores convirtiéndose en el
segundo país en el mundo en tomar una
decisión de dicho calibre pero la
vacunación infantil contra el covent 19
no es algo nuevo en la región
uruguay fue el precursor cuando comenzó
la inoculación a menores de entre 12 y
17 años con la vacuna facer a principios
de junio del año pasado seguido por
chile que optó por sinovac unas semanas
después
la vacunación de menores también avanza
en mexico el salvador panamá paraguay
perú república dominicana bolivia y
venezuela países como colombia argentina
o ecuador optaron por la vacunación de
niños desde los 3 años en adelante la
región también ha sido pionera en temas
de vacunación infantil cuba se convirtió
en el primer país en aplicar los
fármacos desde los 2 años arrollamos
sobre las plataformas de vacunas
infantiles y voló dando nos fue mucho
más fácil avanzar en población infantil
que con el resto la vacuna parece ser
que latinoamérica tiene una mayor
aceptación en que los niños sean
vacunados según un estudio publicado por
la revista internacional de acting el
68% de los padres en américa latina y el
caribe afirmó sentirse seguro con
vacunar a sus hijos